okay right tonight there's an extra
challenge because I'm under holdings a
vegetarian so I'm ripping up my rulebook
and allowing her to swap out the
beautiful duck breast for portobello
mushrooms
yes you'll still be delicious now
everyone at home put a pan on for us
hang on
I'm under a hundred good mushrooms now
I'm taking mushrooms mush
you season your mushrooms I'll seize my
dress yeah now really important okay
the season is beautiful yeah both sides
salt and pepper Drive to both sides my
gosh absolutely definite maybe
vegetarian but we're gonna cook them
just as good now it won't stick when we
start cooking these dogs okay we don't
need to the oil in the pan because I'm
gonna render the duck don't put oil in
the pan or mushrooms yes exactly
okay you've now dodged up into a dry pan
well done Amanda okay now from there I
put them off side down don't I
back ducks in now I might just throw
that seasoning yeah we'll check on the
potatoes get your knife and I should
just slice through there gently and they
yep they're about another minute off if
yours already drain and straight away
and put in the back of the pan to dry
out now to go with a duck I've got the
most amazing olive oil mash and these
beautiful
Pak Choi yeah one of my favorite Asian
greens now Amanda yes Paula no take a
bowl oh okay and just slice off the
bottom and basically open up the pack
Troy I don't guess open them up good
girl now from there okay the idea now is
to actually will actually and leave it
there sort of welting will tip almost
like sort of marinate by the end of the
night so take your garlic crusher I'm
sorry absolutely chaotic in to the back
joy did you need yours as a heart right
now that's fine you can own the little
bit in middle lightly seasoned it touch
of salt okay
I'm touching pepper and then a teaspoon
soy sauce did you put garlic in did you
say yes Chris garlic
Amanda watch your language okay sure
garlic crostini oh hey guy you can have
shocking golden chef
a tablespoon of olive oil thank you I'm
sorry I'm just saying if you can
multitask
you're sure it's also manage your turn
yes now let that sit okay I'm just sort
of Wiltshire now get you got best and
just okay turn them over and just let
them wilt there okay now the secret here
is to really put a nice color nice sear
on the duck call portly okay render the
fat down show me what am i dying touch
more all in your poem okay trust me yeah
you can do this yes if you can work with
some account working with you you stay
with me back joy back joy
nothing wilted enough no it's gonna
marinate in there now yeah sorry sauce
in there garlic olive oil that helps to
season it yes as you know sometimes
vegetarian tends to be a little bland so
it doesn't really not here in my house
have you always been vegetarian we just
put up 40 less Daisy sausage that's
exactly comedy nothing a chipolata
okay okay